المشاهدين الكرام الى هذا المجهز الاخباري
نبداه مباشره من وسط موسكو حيث تردنا هذه
الصور الاوليه لاندلاع حريق في مبنى تابع
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه في موسكو اذا اخر
الانباء والصور تشير الى هذا الحريق ونرى
بوضوح هذا الدخان المنبعث من الحريق
المندلع في مبنى تابع لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في موسكو اي صور او معلومات جديده
نريدها فور برودها الينا الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين كان قال ان هناك ما يدعو
للاعتقاد بان اجهزه مخابرات غربيه ضالعه
فيما وصفه باعمال تخريبيه وارهابيه نفذتها
اوكرانيا في روسيا وفي اجتماعه مع مجلس
الامن الروسي اتهم بوتين اوكرانيا بارتكاب
جرائم ضد مسؤولين روس وجنود في قوات الامن
وصحفيين ومدرسين بمساعده اجهزه مخابرات
غربيه